welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the man
that talks about the constant trash can
that is the stand i'm just kidding it
was slightly better this week wasn't it
i know a lot of you had a lot to say
about our breakdown last week
but i'm going in with as much of a clean
slate as possible with this video
to give this show another chance it's
only had about six so far
so we'll try and be gentle now it opens
with ezra miller's trash can man getting
the nuke from the military installation
he's gone full ezra miller again but i
do feel like certain parts of it were
toned down
in comparison to what we saw last week
whether this was done through the edit
or the director just thinking what the
hell have i done
his entire arc has been heavily
compressed leading to
a very short appearance by the character
yet again
it's a shame as in the book the trash
can man actually has an
arc that has him initially being an
enemy of flag
before he's recruited in order to go and
get the giant warhead
it's far more complex and really gives
reason to why he's so afraid of the
ravens
that constantly stalk him however all
those character nuances are skipped over
so we can see him dry humping the
missile head and yet
i'm already back to taking a dump on the
show they don't really explain how he's
even able to carry it to his vehicle
and when he's screeching away in those
urine stained wirefronts
it's difficult to not feel like this has
been taken from another show completely
luckily we don't spend too much time
with him and we quickly cut to harold
who announces that he detonated the
explosive of his own free will
as we know this isn't the case at all
and he has been manipulated by those
around him
including flag and nadine hal to me very
much
represents the sort of real-life lone
wolf killer
who when people take a proper look at
see there's a lot of contributing
factors to why they went off the deep
end
these lonely men are often influenced by
the things around them which grants them
with a negative perspective of the world
and they often start to hate it because
of said developed prejudices
harold believes that flag will accept
him whilst others have shunned him
however due to comments made by the
villain later it's clear that he was
simply being used as a patsy
now the series differs from the work in
some respects and though his fate
in the end is similar in the book it
becomes clear that flag caused his death
when riding the bike to vegas some
supernatural force that he's unable to
completely pinpoint
causes him to swerve however here it's
nadine who tricks him into crashing
by making him speed up so that he can't
break when it comes to a dangerous
bend personally i prefer the original as
it makes flag out to be very
manipulative
and not really caring of those that
serve him i feel like the show at some
point is trying to play nadine out as
the victim
but it's difficult to really feel any
sympathy for her when she's also doing
stuff like this
harold ends his own life like in the
source material but i don't know it just
felt a bit too glossed over for me in
the entry
and he didn't really get the full proper
send-off that i was hoping for you may
remember that when discussing the death
of his old friend teddy
that he had stated he took the coward's
way out clearly portraying how he views
people that take their own lives
however him wrestling with the
perception of that whilst
also having to do it doesn't really get
put into the spotlight
even though it would have been amazing
to explore i think it would have been
great to see him ultimately reduced to
accepting that he was a coward in his
own eyes
rather than the tom cruise-esque figure
that he wanted to be
there was also the opportunity to show
how both nadine and fran
the two people that he traveled with in
his eyes betrayed him
fran because she wouldn't let him back
and 18 because
she well she hated him didn't she now
fran you can't really blame and it would
have been nice to show how him basically
wanting to force a woman to love him
made it so that another woman forced him
to seal his own fate
but these complexities are completely
omitted
the group actually spent more time
navigating a hole in the highway than he
does in his final moments
and yeah to me just feels like he could
have been given more attention
at the expense of certain other aspects
in this entry
now speaking of deaths we also get a big
one in the episode with the passing of
mother abigail
similar the source material she brings a
final message from god to give to them
but unlike the book she passes
immediately after doing this
with a candle snuffing out to show that
she's gone
very very subtle that i must admit now
in the book she lived until the morning
whereas here it's clear that god let her
live to instruct what they should do
and then he came and took her she
explicitly states that franny should
stay behind
and that one will fall which does come
true later on
the group say their goodbyes and we
still haven't really learned about the
backstory of joe
which i feel is a bit of a missed
opportunity it's actually
really messed up and with just two
episodes left
i don't think that will be getting it in
case you don't know the one next week is
actually a finale of the book
and then episode 9 will be a brand new
proper ending devised by stephen king
himself
and the group walk across the country at
the request of mother abigail
and it makes for a nice montage that
travels the vastness of the us
even with mother a saying that i still
probably would have hot wired a car
but it's one of the strongest scenes in
the series so far showcasing flag spies
watching them
every step of the way as well as a sign
that warns them of the slaughter that
they're in for
they discover harald being feasted upon
by vultures
and a note written by him which stated
how he was always left out of everything
it really paints him out as a figure
whose bullying and trauma led him to
becoming a monster himself
and he apologizes but still believes
that he did it of his own free will
however he later says that he was misled
showing that the truth is somewhat
cloudy he signs it off as hawk
rather than harold confirming that he
loves cobra kai
and also that the person he viewed
himself as being died
and that he carried out the detonation
in many ways to prove to himself that he
could do it
larry covers him up as a form of respect
and there goes the most interesting
character in the show
elsewhere we see nadine get the red
carpet rolled out for her in the desert
and she finally loses that v card to
randall flagg
who impregnates her in the source
material she actually had sex with him
twice i think
and the first was right after placing
the bomb and the latter time they did it
on the road which
sort of gets mushed together here whilst
they mush together
i can't show it because of youtube but
similar to both encounters
flag is very forceful and she sees his
true face which makes her hair turn
white
slowly she starts to slip into insanity
and her appearance at the end shows that
the baby is corrupting her
from the inside out we actually see a
mark on her leg at one point
showing that flag has marked her i think
she will slowly start to see the truth
of the matter
i'm not going to be spoiling anything
from the book just yet but
in the work flag wakes up to find a poop
in his bed wait
sorry wrong story uh no she actually
greets those from boulder in the show
whereas that's not present in the book
for a reason that you'll discover later
in the video
now stu is the one who falls and the
rest of the group gone without him with
larry being appointed as the leader stew
being left with a broken leg of course
mirrors the death of harold
but whereas the latter was left alone by
himself glenn's dog kojak returns to
show that he'll probably be spared down
the line
now on the road the group are picked up
by lloyd and this differs from the
source material
as he wasn't present with the soldiers
here though it just makes sense to
include him
as it shows the importance of getting
them they arrive in vegas to see people
crucified
which of course is similar to what the
man who showed up earlier in the season
was victim to
statues of flag have been crafted and we
see that this caesar-like figure is now
pretty much worshipped as a god across
the entire city
there's also a wolf which is another
symbol of the character
and they arrive at the inferno whilst he
looks over the city
like an all-seeing god upon entering the
casino you can hear larry sung in the
background
baby can you dig your man mocking him in
many respects
nadine greets them ending the episode
and leading us to the finale
well well the first finale anyway now i
will be spoiling what happens to stew
and why nadine's fate is different here
so if you don't want it ruined then turn
off now
if you enjoy the breakdown as well i'd
appreciate the thumbs up and a
subscription
so you don't miss next week's breakdown
anyway in the works stew is actually
found by tom cullen
who has been very absent in this episode
as for nadine the reason her rock goes
differently
is because after flag forces himself on
her it sends her into a state of
catatonia
which is why he has to come and pick her
up she's almost unresponsive at points
but awakens just enough to be fully
aware of what's happened to her
and why flag is a bad man nadine
actually realizes that she has to put an
end to it and tones flag to the point
that he kills her which involves him
throwing her off the penthouse
on the way down he can see that she's
smiling and this realizes that he's been
tricked yet again
now her being alive here could indeed
hint that the show is going in another
direction
so though i'll just add that in here in
case we get to it next week and it's
completely different
anyway that wraps up the episode and as
always i'd love to hear your thoughts on
it in the comments below
don't forget that on the 30th of january
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box sets
to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the series last week
a lot more entertaining than this a lot
more of me talking about why i think the
show is bad and why it's not working
so definitely check it out after this
without the way thank you for sticking
to the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
yeah you better be back otherwise
there'll be trouble
you take care of yourself peace